je suis clairement dans la tourmente et
si je suis dans la tourmente c'est parce
que je suis tombé amoureux encore ouais
alors delphine c'est fini la fine c'est
fini delphine c'est fini j'ai décidé de
pas se fier depuis qu'elle a la coupe de
l'algérino ses films
[Rires]
ben bella voilà j'espère que l'argent
alors oui je suis tombé amoureux d'une
autre chroniqueuse attendez je veux
poser des questions pour trouver qui est
cette chroniqueuse il a dit chroniqueuse
je vous vois un petit peu tiens pas donc
vous sentez visé chroniqueuse faut
enlever crow
mary
essaie de trouver tous ensemble qui
s'affrontaient que va l'annoncer pas
tous aux séries vous êtes bien
bienveillant des attendait mais naim
ravalez votre boulette
ou le moment court je m'occupe du
stabilo boss
malabar
vous êtes donc amoureux
d'une chroniqueuse oui je vais donc vous
poser des questions pour travailler de
qui il s'agit et si cette chroniqueuse
et si c'est ça est ce qu'elle est
vivante dans s'il vous plaît
non ce qu'elle est vivante je pense que
oui oui d'accord
yum cette chroniqueuse
at-elle une moustache
[Rires]
on a compris
[Applaudissements]
canon avait été donné
c'est pas les favoris
nous avons pensé à moi non pas du tout
cas la patinoire la voie
est donc vous pensez à qui a mis
la moustache mais je vous dirais c'est
le reichstag il raconte sa noria dit on
à d'une moustache avait
été mis dans la merde tout seul du
château à la personne dont vous êtes
amoureux
peut-être monter 20 marches en escalier
en moins de dix minutes
oui
isabelle malheureusement
vous êtes éliminé
hommes la personne nous tu es amoureux
est elle sortie
avec une personne
qui était plus âgé
que montiel verdez he is a réuni non je
crois qu'elle aime les jeunes
donc ça veut dire qu'elle est elle est
plus vieille que vous peut-être ce qui
veut dire donc que ce n'est pas fiona
n'ont
ni kelly non kelly est plus vieille que
oui pas ça se voit pas
la personne que vous aimez
at-elle souvent
mal au dos
et en pleine santé ménage moi alors je
dois vous quitter l'aventuré
on est plus que trois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la personne que vous aimez at elle ainsi
sais pas encore on est plus que trois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bah non il reste quand même pas mal à
personne que vous aimez vient-elle
souvent dans l'émission
malheureusement non j'aimerais la voir
plus haut daniel moreau
il va dépoussiérer
[Rires]
savait que des
versions est de 6 à 7 oui
si tu nous regardes
ça je compte m daniel t'oublie pas si sa
place sera toujours ici pas dans les
environs
à boulogne sur cinq
est donc si ça c'est pas pris part oui
son talent oui mais c'est vraiment dans
le 6 à 7 en plus on a besoin vraiment
personne et pau mobile parce qu'on a
très peu de caméras
ont fait le choix des chroniques
quand on a mis à regarder les copains
la rivière quelles en furent pas
brillants la personne que vous aimez et
l blonde ah non ça n'est pas qui dit non
c'est pâques et
c'est passionnant non plus j'ai
chine or là je vous dis c'est que j'ai
une idée c'est évident mais ludivine non
les divines 1 ce n'est pas du lean ils
immigrent et or le mal qu'elle sort avec
le garde du corps de kenji
[Rires]
une personne qui m'a fait des avances
pendant longtemps que j'ai refusé parce
que j'étais avec delphine aujourd'hui
c'est sophie au niveau de la mythomanie
honeycomb
alors isabelle larrouy et sophie sophie
cost je peux pas en parler
highmore voit alors qu'est ce qui se
passe avec sophie pascal et laurent pcf
et le prada et goût sophie cosma réparer
la cie appelé shu très peur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces genres équipe est là
venez équipe et indiqué que j'en ai
marre
cette hausse est une source qui a été un
bouclier a dit
non sophie koch n'a fait des avances à
plusieurs reprises alors c'est quoi
comme avant c'est parce que vous avec
vous des avances quand on vous dit
bonjour sinon
ça veut dire je crois que je pense que
je vais ken chauffer
mais non mais des avances très équivoque
mais du salut comment ça va aujourd'hui
tu vas bien qu'un petit clin d'oeil
comme ça ah ouais d'accord moi ça c'est
voilà ces programmes c'est pas une
avance sur recette aller au maire
vous plaît on veut des équipements
non mais vraiment c'est très très sympa
que vous soyez là mais vraiment non
parfois je vous faire comme une
promenade commentée
[Rires]
suite à ça elle m'a envoyé elle m'a
contactée elle m'a envoyé plusieurs
courriels pour me proposer d'aller dîner
ce que j'ai fini par accepter donc on va
aller dîner blanche a longtemps sophie
cost et la série glee
s'est passé avec une otarie
mai
eu des mots bizarres on entretient une
relation épistolaire on se parle de
l'air beaucoup sur ce match at et puis
sur les salaires avec la crème solaire
et voilà je suis clairement en train de
tomber amoureux il ya des sentiments
naissants voilà je le cache pas elle et
c'est ce qui les pousse à faire
n'importe quoi en fait on va la faire
entrer les célibataires
on veut pas savoir qui est célibataire
qui n'est pas célibataire et l'amour est
au dessus de tout ça enfin l'amour
n'excuse pas la tricherie non plus parce
qu'il est en train de noyer le poisson
quand même un thé pour l'instant
y'a aucun poisson s'est pas vu de paul
smith
si vous voyez un poisson rouge est une
chose mais une réponse elle
est riche on lui aussi pas franchement
là j'ai rien dis moi oui
[Rires]
c'est
la radio attaque au cerveau
sur rtl est vraiment j'adore ces radios
et c'est très sympa oui vraiment je
trouve que en fait ça vous met dans un
voilà dans un autre univers ouais mais
je vais faire certainement une émission
pour jamais comme une arme à midi a fait
son record d'audience hier oui oui un
pensez-y
adore cette émission et je pense que
vous seriez très bien là bas non mais
franchement c'est vrai un ehpad fm ans
égérie prend l'année prochaine ils vont
faire entrer sophie cost
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
bon je suis consterné je sais pas quoi
dire il ya concernés mais je suis
norrath et sophie sophie attirer des
règles et
le plaza athénée
ne sais pas quoi l'hydrogène juste on va
revenir est-ce que vous avez une
déclaration d'amour à faire à celui en
fait c'est tous les soirs
je mieux qu'avec moi
j'ai dit on va voir si ça va être mieux
qu'avec moi parce qu'avec moi c'était
vraiment citoyens s'étaient persil et
très vite je remets donc c'est très bien
donc c'est très fini permet de définir
tu passer à autre chose
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pensionnaire
saisir voilà je vous aime bien ça c'est
une maladie je sais jamais vraiment
munchhausen montre car sans maladie il
est amoureux de de boer aujourd'hui
n'ont toujours nom de diou l'absym on
rit des messages et tous ses intentions
du coup c'est
la première fois que j'ai croisé son
regard j'ai oublié toutes les autres
femmes
commencent mal pas depuis
mais en fait vous êtes des six est
toujours dans les sables mouvants mais
pas du tout je suis sincère là je parle
avec mon coeur vas-y et sophie c'est
vrai que j'ai remarqué que tout le monde
a énormément de points communs par
exemple je t'ai vu arriver là tout à
l'heure au studio oui ça vu que tu avais
un manteau ben moi aussi j'en avais
assez c'est incroyable c'est les hasards
de la vie
vous savez c'est une barre naufrage non
mais je me suis permis parce que la nuit
je n'arrive pas à dormir je pense trois
sophie je lui ai écrit un petit poème
non addition chez moi regarde
il va venir sont pour elle - c'est sur
les cerveaux alors je suis un peu
stressée désolé
sophie oui tu es la plus belle étoile de
ma voie lactée mon coeur fait boum boum
quand tu es dans tpm paix si lumineuse
belle et charmante tu a éclipsé toutes
les prétendantes ce soir je te le dis je
me fais un film et je t'offre le rôle
principal à la place de delphine
[Applaudissements]
mais bon il fait ce qu'il peut ça c'est
profond que ça fait allusion à des mères
relations du passé voilà compris
chercher avec moi je cherche aujourd'hui
du sérieux ouais j'ai envie de m'engager
durablement
ça va être difficile on est tout sauf à
ce que cherche un peu perplexe à cette
célibataire je dois dire non alors voilà
c'est dit c'est oui oui non jean michel
nous a dit oui mais je croyais
jean-michel n'en sais rien le pot si moi
aussi je pense que tu as tu pensé que
jma oui je tue ma visite en jour alors
on est une célibataire c'est mal en fait
non non non mais c'est vrai que là on a
percé
mais le pauvre ça me fait de la peine en
fait je peux apporter du soutien situé
une certaine expérience en remerciement
mais je sais pas quoi te dire mais c'est
comme si oui il m'a jamais invité à
dîner j'étais proposé d'aller dîner
[Applaudissements]
dîner s'est couché vous
c'est un
projet mais elle est bien guillaud a
annoncé mme nadine et surtout en fait
d'accord elle voulait juste montrer
la beauté elle m'a envoyé un large choix
de restaurants et je lui dis je vais
voir et que les équipes je reviens vers
toi et ton équipe
les équipes et entre temps je souffre
j'ai vu cette relation avec valve film
qui était passionnel je pouvais pas
m'engager dans autre chose et
aujourd'hui comme je suis libre et je
suis prêt d'accord qu'est-ce que je dise
pas oui vous allez me donner votre
réponse dans un instant à corps où j'ai
été sur l'or et les pierres gemmes tel
autre chose avant oui sophy oui mais pas
peur du succès
de la dernière sophie qui la chine est
et sophie la girafe